foreign
[Music]
perhaps the most common tenant that
workloads require both Legacy and net
new alike is proper network connectivity
regardless of how they run they most
likely need to talk to other services
connecting your Google Cloud VMware
engine or gcve workloads to your Google
Cloud project is essential to run Cloud
native apps and connect them to your
on-prem network
configuring the peering connection
properly is one key to avoid problems
when building connectivity between gcve
Google cloud and your on-prem today I
will walk you through how to
troubleshoot and resolve the peering
connection issues between gcve and
Google Cloud if you are not familiar
with how to create a peering connection
from gcve to Google Cloud I would
recommend you to watch the video shown
in the screen first for the demo we will
use this topology in which we have a
peering connection from gcve to Google
cloud and interconnect your on-prem
network let's start by doing a
connectivity test from compute engine
virtual machine or VM to GCV evm connect
to the source VM and run the Ping
command to any of your gcve workloads
hmm there is no response this indicates
that the VMware VM is not reachable to
investigate this first verify the
appearing configuration on the gcve site
access the Google Cloud VMware engine
portal in the Google Cloud console go to
the compute section and click on VMware
engine
in the network private connection check
the appearing and region status oops
peering status here is showing as
inactive now this explains why our VM is
not accessible this could happen if the
vpcp ring collection in Google cloud is
missing or misconfigured to verify this
from your Google Cloud console go to the
VPC networking page select the VPC and
go to VPC Network peering a VPC Network
appearing with the name service
networking hyphen Google apis hyphen com
should be listed in the appearing table
the connection here seems to be deleted
to fix this issue we create the peering
again and use the correct tenant project
on gcpe site
great now it is showing as connected
let's run the pin command again
it's still not working this could likely
be due to a routing issue
to troubleshoot this identify the IP
address of the source compute engine VM
that you were trying to connect from by
navigating to the compute engine page in
the Google Cloud console
the IP address is 10.128.0.3
connect to the gcpe portal and in the
private connection tab check the
imported routes check if the GCE VM IP
address exists in the range that are
imported
yes the range is here
check the exported routes oh here you go
the routes are showing rejected this is
the reason why the VM is unable to reach
the zcve resources
now let's verify the same in the Google
Cloud console site go back to the
peering connection again and check the
imported route you should be able to see
the subnet range advertised oh here we
see the routes showing status rejected
by configuration this means that the
Import and Export custom routes are not
enabled
to fix this issue click on edit and
check the options Import and Export
custom routes save the changes let's
check the imported and exported routes
again yay it is showing as accepted all
right let's run the pen command again
phew the GCV VM is now reachable
if you are still facing an issue after
checking these options for custom routes
then follow these steps connect to the
compute engine VM instance and run the
trace route command to the vcenter or
any gcve workload machine
review the output and verify if the
correct route is used to gcve machine
it is not showing anything to
investigate this further in the Google
Cloud console go to VPC Tab and select
routes check that out to gcpe workloads
ah this is the culprit here this route
has an incorrect Target IP let's delete
this route
test it again
it is now working we are able to connect
from Google Cloud VM to gcve finally if
you are unable to connect to gcve from
on-prem then it could likely be because
the routes may not have been advertised
from your on-prem to your VPC to verify
if the routes are advertised go to the
VPC page in Google Cloud console check
the imported routes
similarly you can check the imported
routes in the private connection tab in
gcve console if the routes are
advertised then you will see them here
if not you need to advertise them in
your on-prem setup to fix the issue for
more information on connecting from your
Google Cloud to your GCE resources check
out this documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]